[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM SIDDELL: Thanks,
everyone, for coming.
And thanks for inviting me.
I'm Tom Siddell.
I work on the comic,
"Gunnerkrigg Court,"
which we're going
to talk about today.
And working on a comic
is pretty solitary.
You know, you work
in a dark room
for a few days on your own.
And then every once
in a while, you
resurface and see what
people are saying about you.
So I kind of relish
the opportunity
to talk about the
comic whenever I can.
Even when I was coming
over to the US this time,
I was pulled over for
a special question time
by the US border guards.
And they were kind
of interested in how
I was supposed to be supporting
myself here in New York.
And so I was able to sit down
and tell them about my comic.
And now that I have
a captive audience,
you're going to get
the same talk, I guess.
And this talk is going to
be roughly a two part talk.
The first part is just
going to be about who I am
and how I started the comic.
And it's a small
intro into the comic.
But I didn't want
this talk itself
to be a primer into the
story, because I didn't want
it to be sort of
the kind of talk
where you had previous
knowledge of the story.
And I didn't want it to be
for people who were completely
unfamiliar with the story.
So my background is not comics.
So I can only really
give my perspective
on comics and stuff.
And if you wanted a more
academic view of comics,
there's probably better people
to talk about them than I am.
And so I'll keep that
bit fairly short.
The second part of the comic
is what I wanted to focus on.
There are certain
aspects of the comic
that I wanted to talk about--
in particular, a relationship
between two of the characters.
And people who are
familiar with the comic
will know which two they are.
So it might be a
little bit spoilery,
but rest assured there's a lot
more going on in the story.
And this is just one
very focused look
at some of the things going on.
And anybody who is
new to the story,
I hope it interests them to
go and find out some more.
And as James said, keep in mind
any questions you might have.
And then at the end, I'll
hopefully get to those.
So I am Tom.
I'm from Birmingham in the UK.
And comics always interested me.
But when I was
younger, there was not
much of a comic scene in the UK.
You had the choice
between "Beano"
and "Dandy," which were sort
of old, World War II layover
comics for kids.
And then you had "2000 AD."
And that's it.
So I didn't find much
there once I grew out
of the children's comics.
But eventually when
Japanese comics
started being imported
first into Europe
and then into the UK, I
got this love of comics
and realized that they
could be for anybody--
not just for adults or for
kids, but for anybody really.
And so I was very interested
in the medium of comics.
And I love writing and stuff.
So I wanted to
work my own comics.
But the problem was I
absolutely sucked at drawing.
I was really, really
terrible at it.
And I hated art in school.
And I just didn't think
it was a future for me.
So much to the
relief of my parents,
I went into computing instead.
As you can, I've got a
certain way with computers.
So I got my degree
in computer science.
And during that
time, I enjoyed it.
But I didn't want it
to be my full career.
Coding itself is
creative in a way.
But it was missing the
artistic element that I really
wanted to get myself into.
So after that, after
I got the degree,
I went into 3D animation.
And then that helped me get
a job in a small video game
company.
And during that time, I was able
to work on my artwork at home,
sort of just by myself--
self-taught.
And after a while, I
wanted to start a comic.
So I set myself
some guidelines just
to stick to to try and box
myself in and have a project
to work on.
And so some of the limitations
I set for myself was I
wanted to be able to work on
it two or three times a week.
I needed to put it
online without fail,
because I felt that an updated
schedule was really important.
And it was going to
be drawn very simply.
It was going to have flat
colors and hopefully improve
as the comic went on.
Not quite as simple
as this picture,
but with scope for
improvement as it went on.
And as for the layout, nothing
fancy-- just a tried and true
formula.
I wasn't really a fan
of the infinite canvas
concept of comics where
the whole computer
screen is your canvas and
you can do unlimited things
with it.
I wanted something
that potentially
could be printed in the
future, but it was not really
my end goal.
I also wanted to not alienate
any particular readers.
So when I wrote the
story, I decided
that I didn't want to
focus on or rely on things
like violence,
and sex, and gore,
and swearing, that
sort of thing.
But not write it in such a
way that it was just for kids.
I wanted everybody to read it.
And above all, I wanted it to
be written to my own interests.
And that's one of the things
I learned at university
was if you're
designing software,
if you design it
for yourself, you
have at least one happy user.
And so that's how
I wrote the comics.
And as long as I'm
enjoying it, then I'm
happy to keep working on it.
And so with that in
mind, what I came up with
was "Gunnerkrigg Court."
And the court itself is a
large industrial complex
that is somewhere in the UK.
It stretches off
into the horizon.
It's impossibly huge.
And it's so big that
even though there's
many people that live there,
it seems very empty, very
solitary, very rundown.
And the story is
about two girls that
live and go to school there.
And they share the court
with their families
and their classmates, and also
a bunch of mythical creatures,
and monsters, and robots.
And across from the
court over a big ravine,
there is a forest which is
similarly huge and winding.
And it's full with
creatures from mythology
that I was interested
in writing in.
And the reason
why I did this was
because I couldn't decide
if I wanted to do a science
fiction or a fantasy story.
So I did both.
And I put them
against each other.
I separated them out physically.
And then I made them
really mad with each other.
And that sort of
sets the background
to the story where the
technological side of the court
is kind of at loggerheads
with the mystical side
of the forest.
And that relationship
is kind of exemplified
with the main characters.
The first character is Annie.
She comes to the court at
the beginning of the story.
She's the one who we see most
of the story through her eyes.
And she arrived at the court
just after losing her mother
and her father disappears.
And she's not
particularly bothered
by all the strange
stuff that happens
in the court-- all the monsters
and the scary stuff that
happens.
And it turns out as
the story goes on
that she starts to foster
supernatural powers herself.
And on the other
hand, her friend Kat,
she lived her whole
life in the court.
But she's completely
bewildered by the stuff
that Annie introduces her to.
She's very mechanically minded.
She's an amateur roboticist.
She likes regular kid
stuff like comics and TV,
video games, that kind
of thing, and robots.
And so in these two
characters, they're
very opposite to each other just
like the court and the forest.
But in their relationship, their
oppositeness is complementary.
And it's the differences
between the two of them
that draws them
together and allows
them to be much closer
friends, and allows
them to work together in ways
that alone, neither one of them
would have been able
to do on their own.
So in this story, you have
plenty of other relationships
and characters like lonely
ghosts, strange girls
who can distort reality.
You've got shadows and robots
who turn out to be friends.
You have classmates with
their hidden romances.
And a large part of
the story, I wanted
there to be a
feeling of the fact
that the teachers and the
parents of the children
were also fully
fleshed out characters.
They have their own backgrounds.
This is a photo of a
lot of their parents
when they're younger
in the story.
And I wanted them to be not
just parental figures and not
just teacher characters.
I wanted them to feel like
fully-rounded elements
of the story themselves.
And you also get this guy.
This is Coyote, the trickster
god who lives in the forest.
And he causes a lot of
trouble for the court
and the main character.
And he's basically a jerk.
But he's not the one
I wanted to focus on.
The relationship I
wanted to focus on
is Annie and one of Coyote's
minions, I guess, Ysengrin,
this wolf guy here.
So this is kind
of an illustration
of the sort of thing
you'd see in the story.
Like I said before, just a
very focused look at an arc
that I particularly enjoyed and
I wanted to explore in a way
that I found
interesting to myself.
And so when I do get
the chance to talk
to people about my
comic, I like to ask
people who their favorite
is just to get some feedback
and see what I'm doing
right, when I'm doing wrong.
And in stories, not a lot of
people like the main character.
Not because they're bad, but
because the main character is
usually the viewer stand in--
the every man that you can
identify yourself with.
So a lot of people tend
to pick the more visually
striking characters and
more interesting ones.
But personally, I really enjoy
the main characters in stories.
So I wanted the main
character of my story
to also be personally
interesting to myself.
So even though I'm very
interested in the two
main characters, my
personal favorite is Annie.
And she kind of has to be,
because she's the character
that I write the most.
And I have to know
all about her.
And she has to be
personally interesting to me
to continue writing her.
And I enjoy revealing parts of
her personality to the readers
as the story goes on.
And so when she's
first introduced,
she is very cold and stoic.
And she has trouble
talking to people.
And this is because of
her past in the hospital
where she grew up.
But after her mom
died in the hospital
and she came to
the court, she just
seemed very not able to
interact with anyone.
And she's very solitary and
not really scared by anything.
And this is due
to the experiences
she's had in the hospital.
And I wanted her to be not
just a reactive character
who is bewildered and
amazed by the stuff that
happens around her.
I wanted her to be very active
in the plot of the story.
And sometimes the bad decisions
she makes and her experience
she had really drives
the plot forward,
because she does make
a lot of bad decisions
throughout the
course of the story.
And the other guy
is this, Ysengrin,
When he's first introduced,
, he is a brute.
He is a minion to
the god, Coyote,
who is tough to compete with in
terms of flair and excitement.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TOM SIDDELL: Yeah.
So when you look at Ysengrin,
he is just basically
a wolf's head-- an
angry wolf's head--
on top of a weird tree body that
allows him to walk really tall
and tower above everyone.
And he seems very angry
and out of control.
And he seems very proud.
But as the story
continues, you find out
that the pride that he
holds is not for himself.
It's for Coyote that he
is completely devoted to.
And he's very
dismissive of Annie.
He doesn't like humans
at all, let alone
having to deal with a young girl
that he's like sort of thrust
into this partnership
with against his will.
And so at this point, I
wanted to talk about the first
of two little arcs in the
story that kind of exemplifies
their relationship
and how that changes.
So this first part, Ysengrin,
is fishing alone in the forest.
He's using his strange tree
root body to spear fish.
And we see him shed his body
to come and eat the fish.
And we see that underneath
this strange exterior,
he's an emaciated,
very frail looking
wolf that can barely stand up.
And this is something
we've not seen
at this point in the story.
And he can barely
stand to eat this fish.
And it's kind of a
pathetic scene really.
It's very private
and he's alone.
Unfortunately for him, Coyote
has brought Annie along.
And they're watching
him from the bushes and
because Coyote is who
he is, pushes Annie out
in front of him, which
completely incenses Ysengrin.
He's very angry to have been
found in this vulnerable state.
And Annie has no
idea what to do.
She makes a very
poor decision here
where she tries to
help him up, which
is the exact opposite
thing that you should do.
So he gets her to back off as
he slinks to his tree body.
And he gets to beef
himself back up again,
and be strong, and then
face off against her.
And of course, Annie's
very scared here.
But she is standing her ground.
And just before anything else
can get any further, old Coyote
comes along and
diffuses the situation,
and then takes Annie off
on a mystical journey,
a little interlude.
And these pages are sort of what
you would find in the story.
But I've taken
all the words off,
because it's not important
that you read along
what's going on here.
It's just that they've
gone off and gone
on this magical journey.
And if you're interested,
you can read more about it
at gunnerkrigg.com.
But since that's
not the focus, I
want to go back to just after
that scene happens where
it's time for Annie to go home.
And Ysengrin is made to
carry her back on his arm.
And while he does that, as
they're traveling back--
I left the words here--
she takes the opportunity
to try and apologize to him.
And he says to never apologize
for what is not your fault,
because as soon
as he saw Coyote,
he knew that Annie was
tricked into that situation.
So he doesn't hold any
malice towards her.
And this is the first time
that Annie and the readers
see that he's not really
a hateful creature.
He was just put
in a bad situation
and he's not holding
it against Annie.
And so later on in the story,
Annie gets some very bad news.
And she is distraught.
And she actually runs
away from the court
in a fit of anger
and desperation.
And this is a new
side we're starting
to see of Annie, who at this
point has been very distant
and emotionless.
We see that she's actually very
filled with an anger inside her
that she has trouble
controlling, which
leads her to run away.
And that's where the
scene comes from here.
She runs into the court
and instinctively runs
towards Ysengrin, somebody
she's had a you couldn't even
call it a professional
relationship with at best.
They tolerate each other.
Or at least he
tolerates her barely.
But he runs into the forest and
he picks her up and carries her
into the forest.
And he tells her that he
is disappointed in her,
because she is weak.
And this makes her angry.
But the truth is that she
is weak, because everybody
starts off as weak.
And the point that he's making
is she might feel weak now,
but what she's just gone through
has made her a bit stronger.
And all she can do is continue
to take these experiences
and make herself stronger.
And then this allows her to
spend the summer in the forest.
And over the time, they're
able to get to come closer.
And the relationship
changes a bit.
She's a lot freer.
And she's a lot more
comfortable in herself.
And she realizes that
Ysengrin, despite
his outward appearances,
is not just an angry wolf.
And she takes the opportunity
to become closer to him.
So the second part I
wanted to illustrate
is after she's
returned to the court,
she is tasked with learning
about the inner workings
of the forest.
And so in this
scene here, Annie is
learning about the
creatures of the forest.
Ysengrin wants to teach
her and help guide her.
So they come to this very
dark area of the forest
that she's never been to.
And it's full of big,
horrible, scary creatures,
kind of like Ysengrin.
They're very
aggressive and they're
very dismissive of Annie.
These are inhabitants
of the forest
that Annie has not had
any experience with.
And because of their
nature, a fight breaks out.
And Annie can do nothing but
just roll out of the way.
And luckily for her, this is
Ysengrin's bread and butter.
So he gets to work
laying down the law,
because he is in charge of
these creatures essentially,
which is why he
brought her here.
But Annie, she can do nothing.
All she can do is sit back,
and watch, and be distraught.
And at this point, it's actually
Coyote who comes to her,
and pulls her aside in private,
and gives her some advice,
because Annie doesn't know
what to do or how to help.
So Coyote says, well start
speaking their language.
And when she comes back
and sees that Ysengrin
is being overwhelmed, Annie does
what any sane person would do
and sets him on
fire, because one
of the things we
learn about Annie
is that she can control this
fire that is inside her.
And she can decide what
it does and does not burn.
So she projects the fire
around Ysengrin to protect him.
And she projects it
around herself as well.
And she stands her ground.
Even when the creatures
come up to her,
she doesn't attack them.
But she doesn't allow
herself to be attacked.
All she does is stand
there and make it clear
that if they get closer
to her, they will just
be harming themselves.
And so she makes this
display of strength.
She doesn't insult
the creatures.
She doesn't try to make
them feel small or stupid.
She just stands
her ground and even
lets them know that she's
there for diplomatic reasons.
If they need to talk to
her, then she's there.
And these creatures,
they are at least
smart enough to understand
that they can't really
mess with her.
And so in their world,
their understanding
lets them know that they
shouldn't mess with her.
So they slink away.
And after this,
Ysengrin is very happy.
This is like the only time
you see him like this.
He's tossing her
up into the air.
He's calling her beautiful,
which people don't really
say to Annie at all.
It's not the kind of thing
you'd say shamelessly
like Ysengrin would.
But he's a wolf.
It doesn't matter to him.
He's just ecstatic at the
strength that she showed
and how she comported herself.
And so after that,
the two of them
have gone through
an ordeal together,
not just in this particular
instance, but in their lives.
They both had a very tough
life, very solitary lives.
And they find a unique
closeness in each other
that they don't find with their
other friends and compatriots
that they might interact with.
Annie learns that the anger
she might have is not in itself
a bad thing.
And she learns to
control it is probably
what is the path to
maintaining her own feelings.
And Ysengrin also,
he becomes a lot
more comfortable with Annie.
You can see here that
he's shed his body.
And he is laying next to her
as she tends to his wounds.
And just him doing that is
a big compliment to Annie.
They don't acknowledge it or
he doesn't change his behavior
at all.
But you can see
that compared to how
they were at the
beginning, just the fact
that they are together
like this shows
that their relationship
has changed a lot.
And so their
relationship continues
to evolve throughout the story.
More stuff happens in
the comic, but that's
where this illustration ends.
And they continue to
change, because there's
a lot more to Annie that's
going on and evolves.
But the reason why I
wanted to explore this--
why I wrote it and why I
wanted to talk about it today--
is because it's the
sort of relationship
that I feel I don't see very
often in a lot of pop culture.
I think there are a couple of
messages in their relationship
that I think runs counter
to a lot of popular messages
you see in stories.
And those messages are one,
you should let your emotions
lead your decisions.
And two, accept anger.
Don't let anger
decide your decisions.
In fact, anything that could be
classed as a negative emotion,
you should either ignore or you
should fix it, because you're
broken in some way.
And I didn't want to make
that sort of comment.
It might be true in
some circumstances.
But here I wanted to show
that two characters can
have a close
relationship that is not
particularly traditional.
Their emotions are strong.
And they're strong
for each other.
But they don't rule
their relationship.
Ysengrin himself, he advocates
control and management.
And he doesn't show a lot of
these outward emotions, which
I feel that is often shown as
a very negative personality
trait.
But in this instance, Annie
doesn't try and change
that in him.
She actually comes to understand
that that is how he is.
And she has a reverence
for him that she doesn't
have for a lot of
the other characters,
because they can sit
together in silence
and barely talk for a long
time and be very close.
And it's very different to the
sort of touchy feely friendship
she has with her other friends
like the main character, Kat,
the very regular relationship
that two kids might have.
But here I wanted to
show that not expressing
these emotions, as I
said, was not particularly
a negative thing,
because sometimes it's
OK if you choose not
to show your emotions.
Or if you feel that
you can't show them,
that's also fine, because I
felt that an emotion is not
purely positive or negative.
For example, like happiness--
a pretty positive emotion.
But what if it's happiness
for someone's murder?
You know, that's
not very positive.
Or let's say greed or
jealousy sounds bad.
But what if desire forces
you to work harder and buy
that car that you want.
You know, that's helped you out.
Or hate, for example,
seems pretty bad.
But what if you
hate your wallpaper?
You change your wallpaper.
What if you hate your job?
If you leave that hate to
fester, it will go bad.
If you use that hate
or dislike to motivate
you to do something else, does
that mean that it is now good?
In my opinion, an emotion is
just a thing that happens.
And it's what you do
with them that decides
whether they're good or bad.
And so this is why
Ysengrin promotes
taking an emotion like pain
or the painful experience
that you might have had, and
solidify it inside yourself.
And use that as part of
the foundation on which
to build your character.
And he also advocates for
keeping these emotions
in check.
And for someone
like Annie, who is
liable to literally
spark off at any time,
it's very useful for her.
And it's the sort
of guidance that she
doesn't get from other
people who don't quite
understand who she is.
And with Ysengrin, if you
were to look at him in person,
all you would see is a big,
angry wolf guy on a tree.
And that's probably
what he wants to show.
But it takes someone to
actually care for him
and understand him that he
is something more than that.
And he's just made the decision
to keep that at arm's length
and keep other people that he
has no time for if he decides
he keeps them at arm's length.
So when he does show
a flair of emotion,
it's a lot more
powerful to whoever's
there on the receiving
end as long as it's not
causing any damage, I guess.
And Annie realizes that
she is the same way.
When she joined the court, the
reason for her stoic appearance
is basically the same thing
that Ysengrin has done.
She finds it hard to deal
with the emotions that
are inside her, not just
because of losing her mom,
or being transferred
to a new school,
or coming to terms with
these powers inside her.
She's just blocked
them off and tried
to ignore them completely,
which is why she does lead
to making some poor decisions.
And the two of them have had
tough times in their life.
And because of this, if you
were to try and be overly
affectionate with a
creature like Ysengrin,
you would push him away.
And similarly with
Annie, if Ysengrin
was to try and deal with
her with a light touch
or with kid gloves, she
would lose respect for him.
And I think it's this
that draws them together.
And that's not to
say that Ysengrin
is right about everything.
In the story, a lot
of the characters
question his advice
and his sanity.
And Annie does get
a lot of support
from the other characters too.
But it's very different
to the kind of support
that she gets from Ysengrin.
So Ysengrin's advice is
really from his point of view,
from his experiences.
And when I was writing
these characters,
I like to sort of put
myself in their shoes
and figure out how they would
respond to certain situations.
And I think any
decent writer would
be able to write
characters that are
very different to themselves.
But in this case--
in fact, throughout
a lot of the story--
I find that a lot of the
scenes and scenarios that I'm
writing and exploring
are parts of myself
that I wanted to explore and
get straight in the story.
In fact, throughout
the whole story,
there's certain elements
of my life like places
where I used to go to
school, hints of teachers
that I used to like
back in school, friends
that I don't see anymore,
stuff that's personal to me
that only I would notice.
And I think the readers
appreciate that,
because they feel that
it's a lot more genuine.
And what this means is that
I hear a lot of good feedback
from the readers, because
they start to empathize
with a lot of the situations.
And they realize that I'm
kind of doing the same thing.
I'm exploring parts of myself.
And I think this works,
because people like
to see themselves in stories.
It lets them know that they're
not the only person going
through a certain situation.
It's easy to assume
that as a person,
you're the center
of your own universe
and everything else
is outward from that.
Everything else
is just something
that you are experiencing
for the first time.
And it's easy to assume that
you're the first person ever
in history to feel an emotion.
And I think people gravitate
toward stories that show them
that they're not alone
in that sort of thing,
because in reality, nobody
knows what they're doing.
And we sort of
look for people who
say that they know
what they're doing.
They look for situations
that they can empathize with,
because--
I don't know-- I
guess it just makes
you feel a bit more
understood even if you're just
passively reading something.
So I think this is an
underlying, common thread
throughout everyone.
Personally, I'm not a
pink-haired fire girl.
And I'm not an emaciated
talking wolf that
uses a magical tree as a body.
But I can still empathize
with these characters.
And I think a
well-written character,
people can empathize with
despite looking nothing
like them or having very
similar experiences.
A lot of the times, just
involving similar feelings
that somebody might have
experienced in their life
is enough to draw a reader
into enjoying a character.
And that is what a lot
of the story is about.
And there's a lot of different
parts of me in the story.
But I try and take
those elements
and make them interesting
in their own right
whether I create a character
out of a certain experience
or a particular facet
of my own personality.
I try and make it
interesting rather than
make it into a lecture,
which is what this is.
But people seem to like it.
And from those small
beginnings where
I decided to work on the
comic in my own spare time,
it's updated three times a week.
I've had lots of support.
It was actually picked
up by a publisher.
And the books are now available
in comic stores, bookstores.
And the sixth one
is coming out soon.
And I've been lucky that
people have enjoyed it
so much that they
wanted to support
me working on the story.
And they're interested in
seeing what happens next.
And it allows me to do
things like come and talk
here about it so
thanks for listening.
If you have any questions about
anything that you've heard
or anything related
to it, just speak now.
AUDIENCE: So reading
the comic, it's
very clear that you plan
at least certain things
in advance.
Like I'm thinking of
what's going on right now.
But even what you
showed here, the two
parts of that arc between
Annie and Ysengrin,
there was like a year
or two between them.
TOM SIDDELL: That's right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering,
how in detail do you plan--
Yeah.
TOM SIDDELL: In
detail, plan the comic.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How far
ahead, and how deep?
TOM SIDDELL: Yeah.
A lot of people are interested
in knowing whether or not
I know actually where
this story is going
or if I'm just making it up.
The answer is that I know
exactly how the story will end.
I know what will happen
to each of the characters
along the way.
But I couldn't tell
you how long it will
take to get to those points.
I have sort of a
roadmap of points
that I need to hit along
the way that will ultimately
lead to the ending.
So the stuff with Annie's
development and the stuff
with Ysengrin, that
was planned basically
when I introduced
those characters.
But as for how soon I
get to developing those,
it's kind of malleable.
You know, if I find
something I'm interested in,
as long as it
pertains to the plot,
I might take a detour
and search for that.
But then I'll always
come back to the route
that I've started,
because I kind of know
what I need to hit along the way
for the character developments
to actually make sense.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the development
of relationships in
the story, because I
feel like over the years,
you've been writing it
like the development, especially
like platonic relationships,
feels really natural.
And I was wondering if
you sort of plan out
what friendships you want
and sort of tweak it to fit
or if you just let the
characters sort of organically
see who they become friends,
like how that works.
TOM SIDDELL: Yeah.
when it comes to the
plot-specific stuff,
I need to make sure there
are certain characters
are in certain
positions, whether it's
frame-of-mind or
physically in the story.
So I keep track of those.
But sometimes,
characters that I'll
introduce that I never
intended to be friends end up
do being friends.
Like for example, there's a
relationship between Kat--
secondary main character--
and a girl called Zimmy.
And for whatever reason, they've
sort of disliked each other
from the start.
And there's a very
specific reason for that
that I sort of wanted to
introduce at the beginning.
But then on the other
hand, Red, the fairy,
I knew that she was
going to come back.
But I wasn't sure quite
how their relationship
would evolve and change.
And so when a character
like that, if I
know that I have an amount of
leeway to change relationships,
that isn't going to affect the
overall plot-- or even better,
lend itself to the plot.
Then I'll take the
time to indulge in that
and see what ideas
come from that.
AUDIENCE: Your art
style have significantly
improved throughout the years.
TOM SIDDELL: I hope so.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I liked it from the
start, but it changed a lot.
TOM SIDDELL: That
makes one of us.
AUDIENCE: So is it just from
practicing three times a week?
Or are you actively taking
courses, learning stuff online,
having references?
TOM SIDDELL: I was
never formally taught.
So I think it is literally
just spending my own time.
And I think working on it
three times a week, as you say,
is a big reason why the style
that I chose at the beginning
became anything at all.
When I was working
a full time job,
I literally just had part of
the weekend to work on it.
And it took the entire
weekend to get three pages up.
So any practice that I was
doing in visual storytelling,
writing comics, in
fact, or just using
the nuts and bolts of
Photoshop and figuring out
how to illustrate, that
was all done in the comic.
And so I use that
as an excuse for why
things look a little bit
shaky at the beginning.
I was hoping that things would
look better as they continued.
And I still feel that I
have a lot of improvement.
But I can also
mask that by saying
that I intended them to grow
up and look different too.
So I can hide behind
that a little bit.
But, yeah.
It's literally just
working on it every week.
AUDIENCE: Were there
particular manga titles
that you felt really inspired
you and you found yourself
weaving in, or somehow
the elements would
get worked into your own work?
TOM SIDDELL: I can
say, absolutely yes.
I think I would
even be hard pressed
to point out specifically
where I've woven in details.
But yeah.
The first comic
that I really got
into that showed me that
comics should be more
than either for adults or kids
was actually "Dragonball."
I read it in Spanish,
because for whatever reason,
they were imported into Europe
a lot sooner than in the UK.
And I had no idea they
were Japanese comics.
I thought they were
Spanish comics.
And they looked like nothing
else that I was reading.
They were black and white.
But they still looked amazing.
And I really love black
and white art in comics.
And they were crass as well.
Early "Dragonball" is really
crass, lots of poop jokes.
But also it had this
evolution of character
that I really fell in love with.
As you read the
story, the characters
grew up, which is very
contrary to I guess
a lot of comics in general.
But a lot of the
stories in the UK--
like the ones I mentioned,
"Beano" and "Dandy,"
and even "2000
ID"-- the characters
are stuck in this
sort of time warp
where they never get older.
And the world might
change around them,
but it's always the
same characters.
And I guess that's fine
if that's your story.
But for me personally,
I found that development
in a lot of the long
form Japanese comics,
I think that was probably
my biggest single influence
that I wanted to
maintain in this
and have the characters age,
and grow up, and develop
as they go on.
I'm sure there's a ton more.
I bet there's characters
based on aspects that I
wanted to explore
and things like that.
But yeah.
I'd have to go through and
really think about that.
AUDIENCE: So kind of related
to the previous two questions,
I'm wondering like when
you started, did you
have an idea of what sort of
art style you were aiming for?
It's like, oh yeah.
This is like what
I want to do, but I
have to like develop myself.
And like I'll get
there eventually.
And now you're
like, oh you know.
TOM SIDDELL: Yeah.
No that's interesting, because
I didn't have a specific idea.
The goal was kind
of utilitarian.
It was more that I needed to
be able to get it done quickly
and effectively, which is why
the coloring for the characters
is very flat.
The coloring in the backgrounds
can have a bit more depth.
And the characters are drawn
very simply at the beginning.
And it was very different
to how I drew at the time,
because I felt that I
needed a way of getting
the pages finished and then
moving on to the next one,
because I didn't want to fall
into the trap of laboring
over a single page and
then never updating again.
So I knew that I had a
specific goal in mind.
But I had no idea what
it is going to look like.
I'm fairly happy with
how it looks now.
And there are some
differences in my artwork
that I want to
make and expand on.
And I'm hoping that
continues, because I think
if I feel that I've
improved as much as I could,
then that's when I
start to stagnate.
So no, I had no idea what
it was going to look like.
But I did have just
the sort of groundwork
at the beginning to go off.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I've been reading the
comic since high school.
And I wanted to ask
about Kat and Paz,
who I really love
that relationship.
It like really means a
lot to me and a bunch
of like my other
queer women friends.
And I wanted to ask like
how early you started
like thinking about
developing that relationship
and getting those two
characters together.
Like was it like with the
platonic relationships
where it's kind of like intended
from the start to put them
in the same place
at the same time,
or if it like happened later on?
TOM SIDDELL: It happened
a bit more organically
than some of the stories.
But I knew that
with Kat and Annie,
I wanted to introduce the
relationship where you know,
to be frank about it, I wanted
to introduce a relationship
where Kat was attracted
to another girl.
But it didn't cause a
rift in the relationship
that she had with Annie.
It wasn't a situation where
they would stop being friends
or that Annie would think
that for whatever reason
they can't be friends anymore.
I wanted to show that their
platonic relationship can
be maintained while
Kat grows an attraction
with another classmate.
And the choice to
use Paz as the girl
that Kat eventually
becomes attracted to,
that was a bit more organic.
I had the ideas of their
interactions at first in mind.
But then when I wrote
some of the scenes,
I thought that they had a
really good chemistry together.
And so I knew that she was going
to get together with someone
and it was very
likely to be Paz.
And in the end, I just chose
that it was going to be her.
And so I focused on
their relationship
and showed how it was actually a
good opportunity for me to make
Paz into a more
rounded character,
because right at
the beginning, she
was just a background
character like a lot of them.
And in fact, if you were
to look at the first
the first two chapters are
me sort of finding my ground.
That's why they're very
different to chapters
you might find later on.
I used the first two
chapters to get a feel
for working on comics.
Whereas I knew where
the story was headed,
I didn't quite know
what the tone was.
It was actually going to be
more like a murder mystery
sort of story.
And I realized
that by the time I
finished the first two
chapters that that's
not the theme that I wanted.
So during that time when I drew
various background characters,
Paz was one of them.
And I liked her enough to want
to develop her character more.
And I think because of
the format of the story,
I had the freedom to do that.
So yeah.
I think I made a
good choice for Paz,
because she's one
of my favorite ones
that I wanted to
expand a bit more on.
AUDIENCE: That's
another question.
So the court is highly
technological and a somewhat
secretive organization.
TOM SIDDELL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how much of
the current, very large
technical corporations are
you kind of like drawing on?
Or is this kind of more
of some other influences
I could also see?
TOM SIDDELL: Well I guess
from the visual standpoint,
the look of the court is
very much based on Birmingham
where I currently live and
where my family is from.
Birmingham, they call it
the Second City of the UK.
But it's not actually
the second largest.
It's just during
the World War II,
it was one of the
most important.
It's where a lot of the
Spitfires were made.
And the black country is where
a lot of the factories were.
And all those factories
are still there,
but no one uses them anymore.
Nobody uses coal refineries.
And so they're just sort of
left as dilapidated factories
around.
It's being changed now, but
just like any inner city,
it gets developed.
But I wanted to make a lot
of the interior of the court
look a lot like
that just because I
thought it was a nice backdrop
to have everything there.
There's the sense of there
is an era of technology
in the area in Birmingham--
and where the girls are,
they're the main characters--
that has moved on.
And it's empty now.
It's technology that is
old and it's falling apart.
And that's currently
where the characters are.
So it wasn't a
specific inspiration
from particular companies.
But it was that feeling
of technological progress
has moved on and what was high
technology has now moved on.
And I felt that was just sort of
an interesting backdrop for it.
AUDIENCE: So I like
that you wanted
to point out one of these
important relationships
that you're writing.
And I'm curious what other--
there are a lot of great iconic
duos throughout this comic.
And I'm curious
which other one you
like writing the most
besides the other one you
talked about today and,
of course, Annie and Kat.
TOM SIDDELL: One that
I found interesting
and I had a good
time working on was--
spoiler alert, I guess--
is a relationship that's
actually come to a close.
It was Mort's
introduction to the story.
Mort is- there he is
on the top right--
he's a little ghost boy.
And as soon as he was
introduced into the story,
I knew how he would
exit the story,
because he had a
very, very closed arc.
And he was like one of the
first characters introduced
into the story really early on.
And when he was
able to leave, it
was like finally, I
can show everybody
what I had in mind for
this boy and give him
the final send off.
And I didn't dwell
on it, but I did
want to sort of
touch on the fact
that he's a ghost that
hangs around in the court,
but he'll never get older.
And he knew that Annie and
Kat were going to grow up.
And so he used that opportunity,
as well, to exit the comic
or, I guess, the world.
And I really enjoyed writing
him and drawing especially
his final chapter, where
I get to show his past
and show in no uncertain terms
how he came to be where he is.
And there's a sense
of satisfaction
in wrapping up a long
running thread like that.
But as for other
characters, I like Jones.
She's-- I guess she's
not up there-- but Jones,
she has a really strange
relationship with Eglamore that
I've not really gone into
very much yet and I'm looking
forward to doing that.
There's a lot of relationships
that I really look forward
to exploring like
Annie's dad and her mom,
sharing what happened there
and showing how things
have ended up where they are.
And Jones I like in
particular, because she's
a common thread throughout
a lot of those stories.
And I couldn't pick
a particular favorite
just because they have
to be interesting to me.
Otherwise I wouldn't have
them in there at all.
Zimmy and Gamma, for example.
I love writing those two.
And I want to write
comics about them
separate from the main story.
But in the meantime, they're
in and out of the comic
when the plot needs them there.
AUDIENCE: Is there a
large Polish population
in Birmingham?
TOM SIDDELL: Yes, there is.
That was one of the inspirations
for writing Gamma as someone
who can only speak Polish.
But I guess they
gravitated there
after-- again,
after World War II,
there was a shortage of workers.
So there was a lot of
European migrants looking
for work from Poland and
I guess from Jamaica too.
So there's a large--
and middle European population
just there that I thought
was interesting.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: I've got one.
TOM SIDDELL: Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: So I noticed in some
of the more recent comics,
there's been essentially
a moral debate happening
in all of the reader comments.
So they've been debating,
did this character
make the right decisions with
the information that they had?
And did they needlessly
endanger other characters?
And one of the things that
happened immediately afterwards
was kind of a quieter
patch of the comic where
two characters
actually discussed
the moral implications and the
decisions that they have made.
So to what degree did
you sense that coming on?
Or did you see what was
happening, the response you
were getting from
readers, and feel
that it was worth a response
in the comic itself?
TOM SIDDELL: Yeah.
Well the way that
I work on the comic
is that I draw with
a large buffer.
And this was part of what
I set up at the beginning
to make sure I didn't
miss any updates.
And that buffer is roughly
two months worth of comics.
So if I was to keel
over and die right now,
you'd at least get
some more comics
to read for a little while.
But what that means is
that I don't generally
have the time to, if I
feel the reader reaction is
strong enough that I need
to address it in the comic,
I literally just don't have
the time, because by the time
people are reading
what's happening now,
I've already drawn
two months ahead.
So the stuff that
is happening now
that some people
are speculating,
well he's done this to
address our comments,
turns out I actually
wrote the scenes
originally knowing that people
would have these questions.
And now I'm addressing them.
So I don't know.
Whether that makes me
seem smart or lucky,
it just so happens that what
they're talking about now
is the stuff that a
lot of the readers
were discussing
amongst themselves.
And so at least I can say
that I had the foresight
to anticipate that people
would have some questions.
But this discussion
is what I wanted
to have after this
particular sequence of events
that you're talking about.
So I guess I looked into it.
Anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Returning to the theme of like
the progression of the artwork,
I know that there are a
couple of webcomic artists
who have eventually come back
and redrawn early panels.
Given like the overarching
theme of like growth
and the personal journey
focus of your talk,
do you have a
philosophical disagreement
with this practice?
TOM SIDDELL: Oh no, not at all.
If people want to do that,
then all the power to them.
But it's something that
I am never going to do,
because I've seen
it happen before,
but it's very easy
quagmire to get
stuck in where you can
put your comic on hold
and then go back and
start essentially
redrawing it from the start.
Some people have
the time to do that.
There is a lot of value
in that, especially I
think if you're doing a much
shorter, self-contained story.
And if I was doing
that, maybe I'd
want to go back and
redraw some elements.
But for me, I can look back
at the beginning of the story
and understand that that's
all I could do at the time
and be glad that I've
progressed to a point where
it does look different.
So I've made the active decision
to not go back and redraw those
even though it's been
tempting sometimes.
I mean there's been
one or two areas
where I've had to
reformat the text,
because it was too close to
the side of a word bubble.
But that's about
the extent of it.
Yeah.
I didn't want to get
stuck in that trap.
AUDIENCE: I came in late so
I might have missed this,
but how do you draw them?
And thanks for coming here.
TOM SIDDELL: Thank you.
How do I draw who?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Just how do
you draw the comics?
Like what do you use for it?
TOM SIDDELL: OK.
Yeah.
I could spend ages
talking about this,
but I'll try and give
you the quick version.
When I started, I drew
it on printer paper, just
A4 printer paper with pencil.
And then I used to
fine liners to ink it.
And then I would scan it.
After a while, I didn't
like that process
so I switched to
what I'm doing now,
which is currently all digital.
It's the same exact
processes, but I just
removed the step
of having to worry
about erasing lines and
destroying my paper before I
can scan it.
So I draw it all.
I sketch the pages according
to a script that I have.
I draw them currently
in Photoshop.
And then ink them.
And I color them either
entirely in Photoshop
or I use another program
called Corel Painter.
I guess the ones that
are examples here
that are in the story
themselves are colored
in Photoshop with
some brush tools
that I've developed myself.
When I do illustrations--
let's see if I can find one--
I do take it into a
different program that
handles colors and colors a bit
better like this one would have
been done in Painter just
because it handles color
a bit differently
for illustrations.
So yeah.
It's not a very specialized
way of working on the comic.
And again, it's because
I needed a simple way
of getting it done.
I think in the
future, I might be
looking to move
away from Photoshop,
but still maintain
a similar look.
But that's just because
Photoshop is not
really built for illustrators
and comic artists.
It was very much a tool that I
had to maneuver into a position
that I could get it
to do what I wanted.
AUDIENCE: All right.
I think that's all
the time we have.
TOM SIDDELL: OK, great.
AUDIENCE: Let's thank
Tom for coming out.
[APPLAUSE]